I have video for you of white
nationalists doing the Heil Trump Nazi
salute to celebrate incoming president
Donald this is video from not some
basement in Oklahoma but from the Ronald
Reagan Building in Washington DC for the
annual conference of the National Policy
Institute which describes itself as
quote an independent organization
dedicated to the heritage identity and
future of people of European descent in
the United States and around the world
Richard Spencer was a speaker widely
associated with the alt-right movement
that we profiled on yesterday's program
here's a bit of the actual speech and
then we'll get to to really what I like
to call the key moment which is the Nazi
salutes let's start with part of the
speech though to be white is to be a
striver right a crusader and explorer
and a conqueror we build we produce we
go upward and we recognize the central
why of American race relations we don't
exploit other groups we we don't gain
anything from their presence they need
us and not the other way around within
the very blood in our veins as children
of the Sun lies the potential for
greatness super inspirational right he
also referred to the mainstream media as
the lugan press a term he said he was
borrowing from quotes the original
German very Hayek factor here you know I
don't know whether kids should be seeing
the the 19 seconds of video that I'm
about to play for you I I don't know
what the answer is I know it's probably
more damaging than Janet Jackson's
nipple during a Super Bowl halftime show
that I can tell you with certitude but
you make the call here is what I call
the key moment this is the white
nationalists doing the Heil Trump to
celebrate incoming president Donald Heil
Trump Heil our people hail victory
yeah
we have people making Nazi salutes and
they are closely associated with the
ideology coalesced and catalyzed by our
new fearless leader and it's not irony
or sarcasm or satire it it is all too
real and is it really that hard for all
Republicans who want to to be seen as
not lunatics to just say this is uh uh
completely unacceptable
period without caveats or critiques
about well we don't like this Pat but
you know what liberal media did during
the election no just it just it flat-out
denouncing of it and I'll tell you in a
second what what Trump said it's pretty
tepid but this is very disturbing stuff
and maybe what's most troubling is how
under the radar this is cuz this comes
to us from the National Policy Institute
yeah which is just a completely
ambiguous name right sounds like a
respectable reputable think-tank
it's absolutely insane and right-wingers
really need to come to terms with the
reality that trumps personal positions
about white supremacy and anti-semitism
and the whole thing as I've been saying
for months those are less relevant than
the reality that Trump is the first
candidate in a long time to really
please these types and I want to put up
on the screen for you how Trump
responded to this okay this is a
statement from the Trump a transition
team or the Trump Organization who knows
I mean the business and the the UH
politician it's basically the same thing
president elect Trump has continued to
denounce racism of any kind and he was
elected because he will be a leader for
every American to think otherwise is a
complete misrepresentation of the
movement that United Americans from all
backgrounds it's ironic how people on
the right like to say you know the left
is just as violent as the right both in
practice and an ideology but you've got
a nonzero and non insignificant group of
Trump supporters that is literally
paying homage to Hitler who was a
genocide Ulm a niak lots of economic
anxiety in the room right it was just
economic anxiety that led to a Trump win
know there were many many factors that
led to a Trump win and some of my
liberal friend
whoo I never would have thought would do
this are actually thinking of getting
licensed to carry firearms patting
people who would never think about
getting a gun and I'm I'm gonna admit it
crossed my mind
I looked up hey if you live in the city
of Boston how difficult really is it to
get a gun uh it's actually pretty
difficult turns out yeah I imagine and I
mean a lot of people's were saying when
Trump was running that he says the types
of things that they want to say but
don't feel empowered to say yeah well
now they're empowered in their coming
out of the woodwork they absolutely feel
empowered and we're seeing it and we
will continue reporting on it it is
absolutely sickening I've talked about
how people of all ages but particularly
Millennials are owning cars less and
participating more in the sharing
economy and one of the more popular
options is Zipcar which gets you a car
when you want it when you need it they
offer all sorts of cars SUVs hybrids
whatever you need it includes insurance
and it includes gas you just pay for the
time that you actually use the car and
you can reserve the car online from your
smartphone over the phone then you
unlock it with your zip card each car
share member reduces their personal co2
emissions by between eleven hundred and
sixteen hundred pounds per year for our
audience
Zipcar is offering $25 a free driving
credit if you sign up at join Zipcar
dot-com slash david support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join Zipcar
dot-com slash David